cette ville c'est disons que je vous
propose de re découvrir au cours d'une
balade avec un architecte qui va nous
faire visiter quatre bâtiments qui
symbolise quatre époques différentes
impossible de retracer toute l'histoire
de l'architecturé à dijon félicien carli
notre guide nous propose donc de
commencer en l'an mil sous la cathédrale
saint bénigne c'est là que se trouve un
bijou de l'art roman
c'est un lieu de pèlerinage où aller
pèlerins venaient pour prier autour des
reliques de saint bénigne et c'est le
début du moyen âge c'est l'architecturé
romane une architecture dépouillé une
architecture un peu sombre un peu
écrasante et une architecture très
sombre
et puis il ya un détail intéressant
c'est qu'on a des soldes de l'an mil qui
sont visibles autour du sarcophage
c'était des jeunes là
qui
ils sont dans un état merveilleux tu
vois les couleurs sont encore très vite
eu voix quand tu passes la manne issue à
des jeux de rouge de vert de plantes
pour continuer notre exploration ces
cinq siècles plus tard que félicien nous
donne rendez vous devant un autre
bâtiment dijonnais bien connu mais trop
peu regarder l'église saint michel
c'est un édifice que j'aime bien parce
que tu sais les édifices qui seront on
mettait du temps pour les construire
votre foi et du coup il ya toute une
évolution de l' architecture mon pass du
gothique à la renaissance
c'est élégant c'est rythmé il ya un côté
un peu parfait
il ya la succession les ordres qui
s'empilent tu vois les colonnes doriques
les colonnes ioniques qui s'enroulent
les les colonnes corinthiennes tu avec
les feuilles d'acanthe voilà ça c'est
toujours repris dans l' architecture de
la renaissance tu je trouve ça dans les
châteaux de la loire à chambord par
exemple notre balade se poursuit sans un
regard pour le palais des ducs félicien
nous emmène place grangier devant
l'immeuble peut-être le plus étonnant de
dijon y a pas beaucoup de gars renouveau
à dijon
oui à terme de trois immeubles qui sont
plutôt sympa c'est de loin le plus beau
c'est un délire tu vois d'aller
compliqué comme ça des dispositifs de
fenêtres de toi tu te rends compte comme
ça c'est quand même cherché la
complication et en même temps tu vois
comme si élégant tout ces courtes ou
s'il ya un équilibre merveilleux de 1
cet hiver
l'art nouveau che c'est un courant qui
durent pas très longtemps ça dure une
trentaine d'années est simple en
réaction avec le 19e ou du 19e siècle on
aime plus construit tu vois on a un peu
mécanisée larchitecture donc c'est une
réaction on veut faire un peu un peu des
pièces uniques tu vois des petits bijoux
ou à des petits bijoux
donc tu as des mosaïques qui reprennent
tu vois les motifs végétaux et a aussi
tout fait à défaut marron là ce qui
était fait repartir de plâtre et
pigments voile architecture elle se suit
jusqu'au vitro avec ses verres colorés
la porte voix qui reprend les cours de
la façade
c'est une oeuvre un peu total c'est au
21ème siècle que se termine la visite
avec le rectorat pattes il ya deux ans
par l'auteur du fameux mucem à marseille
rudy ricciotti alors très simple mais il
est finalement un peu plus complexe
qu'on compte pas une sorte de mot 1000
bâtiments
une momie re avec le bandeau qui passe
tu vas partage qui tourne autour du
bâtiment
mais alors tu te rends compte n'y a pas
de panneaux identiques sur tous
complètement différent donc c'est un peu
une prouesse technique et on va voir
l'intérieur
allez on y va
on n'est pas au rez de chaussée au
cinquième étage encore et
encore trois étages voilà il ya ce puits
de lumière donc qui désirent se ce grand
atrium c'est un peu la surprise du
bâtiment notre balade est terminée
évidemment à dijon il ya bien d'autres
bâtiments dignes d'intérêt et qui
raconte l'histoire de l'architecturé
si vous avez envie de vous faire une
balade un petit peu plus complète sachez
que vous pouvez utiliser les petits
guides édités par le cae de côte-d'or il
en existe un sur dijon et un sur la
ville de beaune